[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
and kevin rose welcome to new episode of
the tim ferriss show but this episode is
a random show episode kevin nice to see
you
dude good to see you brother been too
long
it has been a little while
and
as uh as i'm sitting here you know i'm
holding
this 80 mic
in a probably what is a stand that cost
15 cents to manufacture and we were
laughing a little bit before recording
because you mentioned that you had a
family plan with some piece of software
instead of the business plan because it
saves you like three dollars a month
right
and
i do this a lot yeah i was wondering
like where are you
unreasonably
cheap or sensitive
i still have a bunch of stupid
completely outdated behaviors around
saving like i mean literally
a dollar here a dollar there twenty
dollars here twenty dollars there and i
was like uh and the reason i'm holding
this mic is because my cable is too
short to have
power and this mic
in this confined space at the same time
so
after 600 episodes maybe it's time for
me to invest in a better rig
yeah i mean you have uh you have budget
for that i would imagine
i do have
of all the things that i should put a
little little coin into that would be
one
is there anything that you're you're
stupidly frugal about oh dude there's a
ton of things like this is the weird
thing is is i think it it comes down
from like
being raised with not a lot of cash and
then having a little bit more disposable
income as you get older and
when
when you think about like one of the
things i did is i signed up for the uh
the spotify couples plan which is like
because there's there's like a five pack
or something in the family plan but
there's a there's a special couple's
plan
where it's just two people
and so i did that because he saves me
like three dollars a month but the other
thing though that sucks is like then you
can't tie
any other accounts to any of the other
devices so like for example i have you
know my my sonos is my account
and my wife's account is in her tesla
and then in my tesla's my account and so
like i'll be driving around and like
it'll get switched off because somebody
turns on the sonos or something like
that and it's all because i don't want
to spend an extra four dollars so i can
have those extra couple of accounts i
just want to point out for people who
missed it
two individual teslas but at least
you're saving those three dollars a
month right exactly yeah okay saving
that three bucks
old habits die hard old habits die hard
man we don't have the expensive
it's okay you're allowed
i would also say you know i grew up
where
we would eat we had a lot of tv dinners
growing up right oh yeah
we did not have a lot of money and i
became very sensitive to
wasting food so i would say if i look
back at the
food poisoning or anything bordering on
food poisoning that i've had in the last
two years i'd say at least 50 of it is
self-inflicted and it's from
saving not wanting to throw away food
and then like forgetting about some like
you know some equivalent of like chicken
tenders or something that i got take out
and then i eat it like four days past
the expiration date
and then uh i'm floored for two or three
days so stupid yeah so that's not fun i
used to love dinty moore beef stew we
did a lot of tuna helper at my house
which was odd because the hamburger
helper was way better than that damn
tuna helper that's not terrible i've
never heard of tuna horrible there was
two in the helper back in the day i hope
they discontinued it because it was
absolutely horrible for some reason my
dad was like oh tuna's better for him
than hamburger or something
so it was always when dad was cooking
like when my mom was when mom was
cooking it was like a good meal with dad
when dad had to like step into the
kitchen like out came the tuna helper or
didn't do more beef stew or you know
whatever that was in the cans
oh what a mess
uh all right so we'll segue from
outdated behaviors we could we could do
a whole episode on those
uh where would you like to start i could
kick it off if you want with a bunch of
books because i've been doing a lot of
reading so let's let's let's start with
books and there's there's a little
something for everybody here because i
have been reading
a lot
and in some cases it's more of a show
and tell than reading so i'll show you
the cover of one that i think you'll
particularly like
this is a book called visions of japan
and the subtitle is kawasei that's
k-a-w-a-s-e
hassi h-a-s-u-i
kawase hasi's masterpieces so i'll just
show the cover here
and
it's a it's a beautiful collection of
wood block prints and
some people will recognize for instance
at least one piece of art by
hokusai who has the very famous piece of
these almost fractal-like waves coming
over from left to right these uh ormond
in boats that are coming into these huge
waves and a lot of people would
recognize this particular image
kawa says
style is very different
specializes mostly in landscape trees
and uses snow to tremendous effect so
the
assistance he had ultimately in his
workshop we were helping with the
development of the wood blocks had to
develop new techniques to accommodate
the complexity of the snow and i was
introduced to this particular artist
through maria popova who
created brain picker brain pickings
which is now called the marginalian
which
doesn't exactly roll off the tongue but
so it goes which is an it's a newsletter
in a site that has millions and millions
of subscribers now she's been on the
podcast a few times started as a casual
email to i want to say
six friends at a time and has grown into
this behemoth uh she's an incredible
writer
uh and prolific prolific writer
and she had a post on kawase hussie so
that's number one and it's it's almost
all visual as you can see here
it has crazy beautiful pieces from every
era every chapter of his life and
every possible season and
condition in japan so this brought back
a lot of wonderful memories so as a
coffee table book something that's easy
to dip in and out of that you don't have
to read start to finish that's one
i also recently finished
a book called
a moral man or a moral man depending on
how you read it and i i know that is
deliberate so it's one word
a-m-o-r-a-l-m-a-n
which was recommended to me by mark
plotkin dr mark plotkin who's an uh is
an ethno-botanist
and
expert primarily in central and south
american
medicinal plants but
has a fantastic podcast where he goes
into one plant or or
says uh
set of plants per episode
these aren't like psychedelic these are
like full medicinal like they're both so
there's some psychedelics he he knows
those very very well
but he'll do an entire episode on
tobacco then an entire episode on
cannabis then an entire episode which
will include hemp
and the history of of hemp in the united
states he'll do an entire episode on
coca an entire episode on
wine for instance and it goes back and
covers
the entire
history from sort of day one of human
history as we have it recorded
fascinating show really fun really
really fun i want to hear that tobacco
one i i wish tobacco was better for you
and i say that because i don't i've
never smoked at all
but i have had a tobacco-infused
cocktail one time
oh my god dude those are amazing it's
strong it's strong i was at this
restaurant in san francisco and they had
taken tobacco leaves and they infused it
in this bourbon and they're not supposed
to do this it's like totally illegal
totally
yeah and so i ordered i'm like that
sounds interesting like tobacco infused
and they're like no no like it's real
tobacco leaves are you cool with that
and i'm like well i'm not smoking it i
guess but then i later read you know
obviously any form of like getting
tobacco in you is bad for you and so i
drank it
and one cocktail and i stand up and i
felt like my feet were sinking into the
ground i almost fell over i was buzzed
like super high i was like oh my god if
you never do nicotine and then you hit
that nicotine it's real it can knock you
on your ass and yeah just safety notes
so
there's an entire book it's very
academic and dense so i don't recommend
it necessarily but there's an entire
book and i'm going to come back to a
moral man
but there's a book
called something like
tobacco use in south american shamanism
and it's an older book once it was
published in the 70s or 80s
the author has a name along the lines of
like johann or johann wilbert i want to
say i've read this entire book
and
tobacco use is
is
highly prevalent
across most of the amazon it's consumed
in different ways this is true in north
america as well
and
uh if you look at different ways what do
you mean by consumed in different ways
like what are the different like there's
all different means there's smoking but
there are many different ways of smoking
there are snuffs so you could you have
insufflation so inhaling
tobacco in one form or another often
combined with other things
you have
blowing tobacco either smoke or ground
tobacco into the anus that's one
you have
being serious i'm being totally serious
you have
uh
drinking of tobacco juice which is is
the one i wanted to mention
as
in addition to several others very
dangerous so a number of people have
died in the last few years in south
america as let's just call it
psychedelic tourists who have
ingested tobacco juice i mean you can
end up with tachycardia and heart
attacks and all sorts of issues it's
very
dangerous you can die of nicotine
poisoning so you need to be extremely
cautious about it have you tried any of
these
i have stayed away
i've i have experienced sort of
insufflation a lot of people
now it's trendy i think it's actually
too trendy in the sense that it can do
quite a bit of damage if you're
overusing it but people listening may
recognize a word called
rape
or hape some people say it with the hape
like the brazilian pronunciation because
they don't want to sound like rapey
rape but it is a pulverized tobacco
often mixed with other things that
people will
blow into their own nostrils so there's
a v-shaped
joined pair of tubing and you stick one
end in your mouth
and you've already compressed
some version of tobacco into the other
side and then you blow it into your
nostril and it shoots up into your
sinuses
when you say mixed with other things
what is it typically mixed with
it really depends on it's like a it's
like a cocktail it depends on who you're
purchasing it from which tribe
a lot of these are of dubious origin in
the sense that
many
psychedelic or psychedelic related
paraphernalia and compounds
are
spun a yarn of this incredible history
of indigenous use whereas
for instance
toad so
sometimes referred to as bufo
the the molecule in question is 5 mbo
dmt 5 methoxy dmt there's this entire
story now
versions of a story spun about
indigenous use and
there seems to be no compelling evidence
that there is actual indigenous use
of
the uh buffalo various toad goes by a
number of other latin names but the
sonoran desert toad there seems to be no
compelling evidence that this specific
toad was used as a source of 5meo
by any indigenous group and in fact it
was
ken nelson
an amateur biochemist who was
a genius in many respects who ultimately
through trial and error developed smoked
uh
venom from buffalo various as one means
of of
consuming 5-meo dmt now 5a dmt is found
in other things it's found in other
plant species many plant species in
different types of tree nuts for
instance something called yopo there are
many different sources but
the i guess the point i want to make
which is a long answer to your question
is that a lot of these
tobacco cocktails that are being sold to
blow up your own nostril or nostrils
i don't think have any basis in
indigenous news but sometimes it's mixed
with things that are not psychotropic i
advise
generally against this i mean there are
potential uses blah blah blah but i know
people who just as you can with
cigarettes become addicted to dappe
but because
they're in venice
and
you know doing
like a yoga oscar retreat and everyone's
talking about how highly evolved they
are by blowing it up their nostril
instead of smoking it
suddenly it's socially reinforced and
then you have people who are going
through like an entire canister of this
stuff every week because they're
addicted to nicotine
well and it's it's still they've still
proven that this is like bad for the
heart and like causes cancer like this
different delivery mechanism doesn't
get around that in any way right yeah i
mean you can you can definitely do
plenty of damage i i don't know there
may in fact be medical applications
i i am not well enough versed in sort of
contemporary
medical applications of nicotine i know
that there
there are almost certainly potential
medical applications
which would be administered in some way
that is not smoking right because like
lung cancer lung cancer will kill you
let's be clear yeah
i know that there was a um i had read
something around a study that was done
on the nicotine patches and it was more
around heart health and there being some
potential negative effects around that
but i know a lot of the biohacker
community at least a few people that i
bumped into
they like the nicotine patches the
little slap went on and it's it's a nice
little booster you know you take it with
your coffee in the morning and it's like
you did a rail or something like oh
it'll let you up and it will also
put you on the ground i mean i've i've
experienced
adape a number of times it's it's not my
it's not my like go to tuesday wake me
up or anything but
and i remember doing it with someone who
at the time with someone who who was
using it probably
i don't know 10 to 15 times a week
somewhere he's somewhere in that range
like twice a day
and he had a really high tolerance and
he packed
my
tube
with and he's also like mid 200s
probably in body weight so he packed
this tube and i blew it up my nostril
and
i immediately broke out into like a cold
sweat room is spinning and i needed to
lay on my back for like 45 minutes it
was awful it was absolutely terrible so
don't take it lightly this is a detour
we took off of mark plotkin check out
his podcast plan of the gods he also
wrote a book called
either the or a shaman's apprentice
which is very very good about his
adventures in places like suriname
really knows his stuff he was a protege
of an incredible
sort of father of ethnobotany in the
united states called richard evan
schulte's who was at harvard i've had
mark on the on the podcast before
fascinating guy also runs a non-profit
called the amazon conservation team
which does really interesting work
in helping indigenous communities in
particular not only to secure their land
as protected but also to monitor it
using you know raspberry pi and
technology and so on because you can't
if you can't enforce the boundaries and
prevent poachers and illegal logging and
so on there's not really much value to a
place being protected yeah if it makes
any sense yeah but mark recommended this
book a moral man by a guy named derek
delgaudio so derek delgaudio
d-e-l-g-a-u-d-i-o
i recognized because there is a one-man
show that he did on hulu or it was
available on hulu it was performed in
new york city
with
storytelling sleight of hand kind of
stage
mentalism although a lot of it was just
like brute force incredible memorization
called in and of itself so if anyone
hasn't seen derek delgaudio's show in
and of itself kevin you would love this
awesome it's so good so derek delgado in
and of itself i recognize the one man
show and a moral man goes into his
entire
life story
of
growing up with a single mom and then
learning about magic ultimately becoming
a card mechanic in illegal games like
high-stakes card games
and the whole story
is uh is really good i was very
impressed with the writing so that's
that's one and then the last one i'll
mention
is a novel it's called ca just ka by
john crowley and it is a long book it's
i would guess i wrote it on kindle but
probably four to five hundred pages
about
a
single crow who basically i don't think
i'll give away too much here by saying
it's reincarnated over and over and over
again and develops the ability to
communicate with humans
and
it's a cool book i will warn you in
advance that it takes literally a
hundred pages probably to get warmed up
to the point where you're like oh this
is actually now interesting so there's
a lot of setup involved so be forewarned
but john crowley
is is interesting to me because he wrote
a book another book that takes about 100
pages to get warmed up with
called little
big little comma big and that is one of
the best novels i've ever read in my
life it leaves you in a
altered state for at least left me and i
know uh several other people in an
altered state for a few weeks after you
read this book
which one was that called them taking
notes here where you're saying it's so
good little bit a little big a little
big and i think the an alternate
subtitle or a
sometimes included subtitle
is like the fairies parliament or
something like that but
the pro tip with little big it's so good
it is
i just i'm telling people in advance
it's like some heavy lifting in the
beginning because you have to
establish a bunch of context
once you get to
the talking fish you'll know that you're
about to turn a corner into the really
wild fascinating stuff
but there is a family tree
in the beginning of
the paperback edition which was given to
me as gift by my brother and i put it
down i tried to read it and put it down
like three times and i'm just like why
did my brother give this to me like it's
not that interesting in the beginning
and then when it finally turns the
corner you're like oh my god this is one
of the best books i've ever
read and wow so you're back in you you
gave up reading new books for a while
well i gave up this is like a technical
point
that
i think is worth understanding i gave up
and i still am giving up reading new
books
meaning books that are published
in
this year
but i am reading books so i'm reading
books but john crowley's book little big
as well as cod these were published many
years ago
and the reason i made that
decision and policy is because i get
deluged with
like dozens of books a week that i don't
request they get sent to me and then
people want you to plug them i get the
same thing you get them in the mail
yeah and sometimes they're friends right
very often they're friends i mean that's
like i've done 600 episodes so it's like
of those 600 people how many of them
write continuously and have books coming
out a lot right so i can't accommodate
all of them even if i if i can
have one of them on the podcast
if all i did was read one out of every
10 books sent to me i would never have
time to do anything else so there's this
blog post i wrote quite a while back
called i think it's like the one finding
the one decision that removes a thousand
decisions something like that if people
search it they can find it if they go to
tim dot blog forward slash new books
they'll see it because we i send that
now to people so it doesn't feel like a
personalized
decline in 12 months people don't send
them books all in december and expect it
to happen
well i actually put i put something at
the beginning of it which was like this
has been extended indefinitely so
basically if you're about to send me a
book that is like sent in any new year
like forget about it right so
it's gonna be a tough sell but uh those
are some of the books that i've i've
been
enjoying and
uh i will probably go into i think john
crowley has a
a collection like a three-part series
that is egypt or ae
egypt spelled with an ae so i may dig
into that next but his i think the book
that kind of mesmerized the most people
that i'm aware of is the the little big
and i i left something out so in the
beginning there's a
there's a family tree
do yourself a huge favor and take a
photograph of that or shit's gonna get
really confusing so take a take a
photograph even if it's on kindle like
take your phone out and take a
photograph of the family tree because
you're going to want to refer back to it
fantastic book so
that is some of my awesome information
diet at the moment
i've got one book to mention
yeah go for it peter tia mutual friend
obviously been on your show a bunch
you turned me on he actually had an
episode
of his podcast
the peter t drive where he interviewed
terry real
which is um this fantastic
therapist
mainly focused on actually male therapy
and issues around that males run into
and
he i got invited to join a men's group
with terry actually yeah i'd never done
one of these i don't know if you've done
men's screenings i've never done the
men's ribs i have not it's really
interesting i had neither and i was
invited to join one of these men's
groups and essentially
it is
picture eight people over zoom
terry's there as well so you have your
therapist in the room and i'd never done
any type of group therapy thing before
i've done individual therapy and couples
therapy but never group
and
it was he kicks it off by saying okay
we're gonna go around the room and we're
gonna spend everyone gets
10 minutes that to just tell me what's
on your mind what's going on and there's
none of this [ __ ] like well i took
my kids out no that's like no no what is
it hitting you at a deep level that you
are struggling with and he calls you on
your [ __ ] like if it's such generic
answers because everybody has their [ __ ]
right like the thing that they're
they're struggling with like my spouse
did this or you know
like it could be any slew of different
things that you're running into you know
like right now for me it's my mom's
dealing with cancer right so i like that
was the thing that i went into and
you spend those first 10 15 minutes
and it's really eye-opening and they put
you in a group of like peers that that
when you look around the room you're
like you're kind of in a similar stage
in life
and
you you have these really deep
conversations and one person can be you
know got caught cheating on their wife
or whatever it may be
and
you realize instantly like oh my god
like so many people actually struggle
with the same things that i struggle
with every single day
in my head which is nice it's refreshing
and then the people that are having the
most pain for that particular session
you do this a couple of times a month
it's a two-hour long
session
he'll go deep with those people so say
okay you're the two people today we're
going to go deep with and then you just
watch as he dissects and just ninjas
around and gets them oftentimes to tears
by the end of it
and really really goes in deep into some
of these issues that these men are
bringing up
and
i had never really thought about doing
that and it was really a really
beautiful thing and you're very
supportive like you all you never like
they always say does anyone want to
comment on what this person just said
and it's never
about judging them or saying well i
think you're doing this wrong it's more
like this is how this landed on me
is that a rule that was established up
front it is a rule there's a handful of
rules yeah what are the rules
so you you comment on how it landed on
you and how you see it through your lens
but this is only applicable to you
you can say general supportive things
like like i thought you were really
courageous for saying that thank you for
sharing it with me things like that you
can always pass at any time so if
anything makes you uncomfortable you can
always pass
there is 100 percent like what happens
in this room stays in this room we're
talking about some very
kind of crazy topics here that maybe
some people haven't disclosed that to
their even closest friends or partners
right
there's all kinds of issues that i heard
came up where i was just like i can't
believe we're talking about this but
it's it's nice it's nice to know that
other men are struggling with the stuff
and so
that was fantastic and i've been doing
that for a few months now
and it's led me to just i don't know
there was some great insights in there
that i just came away with but then it
led me actually to terry's books as well
because you know these are quite
expensive kind of groups as terry's a
pretty sought after type of individual
therapist
and so he has this book that he turned
us on to called fierce intimacy that's
one of his books
yes
fierce intimacy and it's great he reads
his own audiobook so it's on audible and
it's how to communicate with love and
respect even when you argue
and this has been just a game changer
for me when it comes to
how i can
relate how i can
prevent self-sabotaging habits
you know
just how to deal with your partner in a
way that is constructive and moving
forward and not judging and being able
to know when to let information in and
take it in and digest it and let it hit
your stuff like internally and when to
know that the other person is just
venting and actually it's coming more
from them and it's okay to put a wall up
sometimes and block that information
because it's where they're coming from
and it shouldn't land and hit you in the
wrong way and it it's it's such a
beautiful simple framework
that i absolutely love and the other
thing i love about him is he was kind of
a pioneer in this space he's not a
therapist that that that that just sits
there and listens to both sides and like
it sounds like what you're saying is
this he takes sides in therapy like he's
like no that's [ __ ] wrong like you're
doing this like she's right here or you
know like and so you hear a lot of that
happening in this conversation and i i'm
like finally you know like yeah i like a
therapist
because sometimes i know i'm right
sometimes you know
so
so i just found this guy to be really
refreshing and i and and probably people
that are some people are laughing
because they know this is a really
popular person i first i had heard of
him was six months ago but he's a very
famous therapist but anyway highly
recommend fierce intimacy dario and i
both listen to it my wife and i both
listen to it and it's already improved
the way that we communicate with each
other the way we have conversations the
way we let information flow in and
actually land on us
so i'd put it in there in terms of books
to recommend how long is that book
i did it on audible so i think it was
like seven hours or something like that
yeah so it's probably like 250 pages
something like that yeah somewhere
around there yeah pretty easy
do you think you have found it helpful
because
you are
also in the group or is it do you think
it's effective as a standalone the book
absolutely because daria listened to not
being in the group obviously and she
found it effective as a standalone as
well and i the reason i like it is it
just doesn't dance around
this like we always have to be head over
heels in love
it's like every single day that you wake
up
one person might be up one person might
be down and it's always about finding
your way back to that middle safe like
comfort zone and relationships are
nothing but
you have these moments of beautiful
things and bliss happening but largely
it's about
the other the other points right and
like how you get
yeah and returning back to that state of
health right and in understanding and
how to
how to both know that you're on the same
team and and have the same goals in mind
and working with a framework that that
supports that so yeah i don't know i
really loved it and i'm not a i i've
really struggled i've listened to a
couple other relationship books because
you know i'm always trying to improve
i've been married nine years now and and
darren and i are in a really good place
now but you know me tim we've had these
conversations like one-on-one
there's bumps with all these
relationships right yeah and it's like
you know dary and i did couples therapy
for a bit especially when you introduce
kids into the equation my god that
changes everything
and so it's it's like this is this is
the first time i read a book where i was
like this this is speaking to me and
working so i want to throw it out there
that's great that's a big deal
you know i i have
considered men's groups a number of
times
i think i probably have
on one hand
like an unfair judgment although i've
seen this before
so it's not totally unfounded like some
men's groups like all right we're gonna
go in the woods and like
you know wear furs and bang on drums and
like yell and scream and i'm like ah i'm
not sure that's
the the medicine i need right now and
then
you know i've had some misgivings at
different points but the
the kind of
meta commentary that i would
i would make and this has been a
conversation and it's a conversation
i've had actually with
quite a few
women
because
i've just observed
that
like women i think are in general again
i'm painting with a broad brush but
better at kind of social cohesion
and
gathering
and that type of
communal
intimacy and
there there are very few places you know
outside of like a sports team or the bar
or
fill in the blank option c
where
men have those
communal experiences but if you look
back at our
just
history right if we look back hundreds
of years thousands of years that was an
inbuilt feature of different communities
and
i think that
that society at large ends up in a very
precarious
volatile
situation when
men especially younger men don't have
that right it's like okay if you have
somebody who is feeling alienated who is
pumped full of hormones like let's just
say like kind of 16 to like
22 right
with no sense of
social belonging
and a lot of
physiologically
driven or at least informed aggression
like that is
a significant societal problem right yes
and
so i've i have thought about that a lot
i mean
go ahead
the other thing too i'll add on top of
that is you know traditionally
when you think about men getting
together and shooting the [ __ ] you know
it's it is that bar setting is that
sports gaming whatever it may be and
it's very high level right like at that
point you're just like i have things
like yeah you know wife's doing this
blah blah
like you don't have the permission
really like in my group i was like
my mom had her cancer return
like
i'm going to miss her when she's gone
because i'm her little boy and like i
will miss the feeling of my head on her
shoulder and like stuff that i'm just
like so deep and intimate to me because
i love her so deeply yeah and it's like
you don't get that over a beer
necessarily to be able to go and to see
other men around the table doing the
same thing because we all at that point
have set the ground rules it's a safe
space and we can we can just really
really let it out and lots of tears come
and one of the things terry always says
that's really interesting
during it
people will start to cry men will start
to cry and tears will slip and he goes
what are those tears saying
what are those what are those tears
saying right now and it's like it's like
give me more give me a more open that
door a little bit further than you're
comfortable opening up like you yeah i
triggered something here come the tears
unpack that further
and then it just goes from there and
it's deeper and deeper layers and it's
released man i mean you know how this is
psychedelics help with this a lot you
know i the number when i did my high
dose mushroom experience i was sobbing
after you know because my father passed
away it was like it gave me that
permission to let that stuff go
yeah and it's it's a very special thing
when when you can do it because it's
it's so healthy
yeah i'd i'd love to actually ask you
because you can probably correct or
at least inform
my initial impression so i i listened to
that episode
on peter's podcast or i listened to the
first half so maybe i didn't give it
enough time but i listened to the first
half and
other people i know have listened to
that episode and immediately bought a
bunch of books
so i may be peculiar in this way but i
listened to the first half and there
he's he seemed my impression was that
terry had a real
axe to grind maybe on
masculine strength if this makes any
sense right so he talked a lot about
like toxic masculinity okay fine talked
about
sort of the counterparts to that and it
seems like he didn't grow up with say a
kind of healthy
interaction with
exemplars of male strength right didn't
seem to have this like the sports
background like he mentions his dad
wanted him to be this like jocular
athletic kid and he wasn't that
but i came away feeling that he had
maybe
a very partial
view of
masculine strength and i think it's i do
feel like it is a mistake and it's also
kind of conformist
group think to automatically like excise
male strength from like the topics that
we can discuss as important right i do
think there's a place for that
so i'd be i'd just be curious to hear
your thoughts because my impression in
listening to the first half i was like
oh wow this guy's like
rah-rah kind of
feminine energy the future is feminine
that's fine but to the if it's to the
exclusion of trying to cultivate
strength in men even if that does look
on some level
traditional even cross-culturally i mean
we see certain sort of typified
behaviors not saying they're all good
like they're
all things in excess can become
sort of the opposite of what we're
aiming for
how would you speak to that because uh
that was that turned me off and it
probably says more about me than about
terry
but it's actually it's it's funny you
should mention that because when i
listened to that episode
i
immediately thought i don't want to go
any further here it wasn't necessarily
for me either but i trust peter right
yeah and i know that peter i know that
peter's a very masculine dude yeah i
mean i watch videos of him shooting his
bow out of his house like into the
backyard from the center of his house
i'm like who shoots bows in their house
into the backyard like he just
he's crazy like yeah
so
peter is as masculine as they come and
you know i i listened that episode and i
thought i think we it was we unfairly
got a very small slice of of what that
he is terry's all about and and when i
listened to this book i was like oh
thank thank god in some sense like i'm
i'm glad it's it's much more it seemed a
little one-sided there yeah yeah i agree
got it all right that's helpful i felt
the same thing you did dude i absolutely
felt the same thing you did i was like
okay this is like i i'm not gonna say
well
yeah i just was worried yeah and you
know i i i think also you know for those
people are interested you can you can
kind of look at mark andreason's
commentary on the the current thing
right he has
a lot of thoughts on like the current
thing in quotation marks and
i don't want to speak for for mark but
the
the i used to start every presentation i
did with a quote from
mark twain and in this case i do think
it's actually verified i know it's like
mark twain abraham lincoln and like
right gandhi and groucho marx get like
ninety percent of all quotes on the
internet
uh or may west but
the
the quote was and i think i'm getting
this right you know whenever you find
yourself on the side of the majority
it's time to pause and reflect
and just to identify like how much of
what i'm actually
not just saying but believing
are conclusions i've come to from like
first principles or actually following
some kind of logical
process or from direct experience and
how much of it is just
conditioning how much of it is
a subconscious or conscious fear
response because i see people having
gasoline poured on them and being lit on
fire on the internet
metaphorically speaking whenever they
voice the opposite
and
i i think it's very very important to
pay attention to that not just with
respect to
you know where we segwayed from with
with terry
but it's like whenever you're like
whenever you're too
in line with kind of what the majority
are saying like it might be true but
very often
we're absorbing
beliefs or perspectives or positions
that really aren't
we haven't earned if that makes sense
like we haven't earned these positions i
mean the same goes true for food like
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm eating
mcdonald's everyone else is eating
mcdonald's maybe this is the best thing
for my body
yeah it's just certainly one way to yeah
that would be that would be one example
uh
so speaking of of of herd behavior um
this all i'll go the other direction
should i talk about my first ever nft
oh dude i'm so excited you you've jumped
in yeah i jumped in and you know i i
hesitated
partially because as as you know since
you're responsible for
sort of pulling my attention
i've been tracking this stuff for a
while right and and thankfully you got
me off my ass because you're like hey
i'm going to be doing this thing don't
tell anybody now we can talk about it
it's going to be called grails and
do you want to be part of it and do you
want to explain just very briefly what
grails was
yeah what it is and then i can hop into
it
yeah absolutely and and for those that
are listening that have no interest in
nfts or read the headlines out there
rest assured that i can tell you that i
too being so deep in nfts believe that
there's a lot of hype in the sector like
there's a lot of anyone armed with
photoshop right now
can publish an nf2 to the blockchain and
that means
that there's gonna be
a lot to kind of like sort through and
sift through to find the gyms and but as
an underlying fundamental technology it
is a sound one and that there's proven
scarcity there's durability of the asset
meaning it doesn't degrade with time
you can transfer it i mean there's a
there's a bunch of great things about it
that it will be around forever i have no
doubt
now that said
you know there was a lot of hype going
on into the world of nfts here and there
still is
six or so months ago and i thought to
myself like let's create an nft project
and call it grails
and the reason it was called grails it
was indiana jones and you know the holy
grail where he has to choose that cup
you know that very very famous episode
there i'll choose wisely and if you
choose the wrong one you like you turned
and shriveled up and died right
so the thinking there was that so much
attention at that time was on flipping
nfts oh i'm going to grab this one i'm
going to buy for five grand sell for a
hundred you know also i'm just gonna
interject for a second also some people
refer to what they might consider like
the blue chip
nfts as grail nfts there's also that use
of the word yeah continue that's right
yeah so the thinking there was okay
let's let's
put the emphasis back on the art and
allow people to look and consider each
individual piece
and then they have to make a decision so
20 artists
20 anonymous artists
all up on the site as a member of my
little group called the proof collective
you got to choose one so you could go in
there and just pick one that you wanted
and then we would do the grand reveal
and so afterwards
we would reveal who the artists were a
hundred percent of the sale
of the nft and the royalties went
directly to the artist so i did not
profit at all
and um you were kind enough to say i'm
gonna be one of those artists that
people have to guess uh if it's me or
not
yeah so there are 20 basically imagine
you go to a website there are 20
thumbnails of different types of artwork
most
if not all
artists who are established
did something that was
sort of
non-identifiable right they did
something a lot of them did something
completely different stylistically so
that you wouldn't know it was them
and
then people were guessing right so
there's a lot of speculation in various
discords and so on about who might be
the artist behind which piece
and when you initially offer it to me
and i'll i'll skip to the punch line
real quickly if people want to see this
what the output was i can go to tim dot
blog slash nft and i'll just forward to
a page on open c where you can see what
this looks like
but i
bounced around a whole bunch of ideas
and then i realized wait a second
about a year ago a bit over a year ago
i wrote a short story and i've never
published fiction
anywhere so i've never had
a fiction blog post that i can remember
i've never
published any fiction in book forum i've
never
had a magazine article that was fiction
and i
decided to
take that which is about
let's say 1400 words and the name of the
piece is how to start a war
i'll come back to why it's called that
because this was written keep in mind
more than a year ago so it's nothing to
do with the current conflict but how to
start awards fourteen hundred or so
words
and decided to make that the background
of this piece and then to layer images
on top of it so i
ended up thinking
on my own and then along with this
designer lisa quine
about how to create something that would
actually
make a nice say poster in a frame on a
wall or a print and i wanted it i wanted
i needed some parameters i needed some
constraints so i was like okay let me
not like blue sky this totally
it has to look
decent on a wall if someone put this up
on a wall
and
the it's called how to start a war
because it is based on a real experience
i had which
i'll let people read the piece who want
to read the piece so the only place you
can find this
first published fiction piece by me is
as this nft that's the only place you
can find it
and
it's an easy read but i the the way it
starts is
with someone handing me a business card
and saying if you want to start a war
call me and then it's like the whole
thing goes down a pretty deep rabbit
hole and most of it is
a composite but true to life which made
it pretty easy to write
and
that's it i mean that's how
it started and
it's been really a fun experience for me
so thank you kevin for getting me off my
ass
all the proceeds from this nft go to my
foundation so they'll end up funding
scientific research and other
initiatives related to primarily mental
health possibly
longevity and life extension or health
span extension but predominantly mental
health and i feel really good about it
so it's been it's been a fun
little
experiment and a chance to also kind of
understand how some of the plumbing
works you know what i mean it's like if
you want to yeah
like there's a point you can only read
so many books about like playing soccer
and then you gotta get out there and
actually kick a ball around right like
you're not gonna really have a feel for
it until you start screwing around with
the actual mechanics and plumbing and
having to do things and you've had some
good success man one sold for 15 eth
which is current prices around 50k
you know you've had a bunch of good
secondary sales
yeah people were pretty pumped yeah and
it was fun to also have the reveal right
yeah so
so i think a lot of people minted
and
uh you know ultimately i hope that there
will be some durable value because it's
not only my first nft but it's my first
published fiction piece so you kind of
get a two for one so we'll see let me
ask you a question
this is uh this is meant to be cut out
if you don't like it
no but a lot of people are actually
adding utility to their nfts meaning
that like
if you own this original tim ferriss
piece something you do in the future
like let's say you do another nft drop
you get some extra special rights or
maybe they come to one of your live
shows they get to do a meet and greet
like have you had any thoughts around
like maybe offering some perks to people
that own and hold your nft yeah i have i
have thought about this you're not gonna
like my answer though and i don't wanna
do it yeah yeah well this leads me to a
question for you actually so
i decided
i want to under promise and
over deliver
or at least not under deliver so as it
stands right now under promise and never
deliver
or just never promise
never promise to never deliver never
promise and therefore you don't have to
deliver
i wanted it to have
to the extent that it can again this is
not investment advice all this stuff
could go to zero who the [ __ ] knows
but
i wanted there to be intrinsic value as
a first
right
and
there is i think to the extent that
there can be
i did not want to make any additional
promises and you know i asked you a
while back and i'd love to talk about it
on the show if you're open to it i have
a friend i'm not going to mention the
name but
this friend has started different
projects
in web 3
nfts and
has made these promises
that are kind of ongoing promises right
and then the value of whatever he has
created
is tied to the ongoing delivery
of more and more things and it's ended
up being a huge stressor for him because
he feels like
a i have to do this forever
b i can't figure out how to extricate
myself b if i don't do that
then when the music stops like the last
people
left holding these nfts will just lose
all their money
so he has tremendous guilt also and
stress around that
so i'd love to just hear how you think
about this
and maybe common mistakes that you see
people make
because it does seem like
more and more promises are being made
right and so when you launch a project
now and again this comes back to the
mark twain thing right like whenever you
find yourself on the side of the
majority it's time to pause and reflect
so i but i've talked to
yet different friends who are like hey
man if you launch a project now like
it's table stakes you have to do this
this this this this private community
this events access
q and a's
and i'm like well hold on a second like
i'm not convinced everybody
can or will deliver those things
and if the table stakes just keep
getting larger and larger and larger
like that is not
ultimately
scalable indefinitely right things are
going to break people are going to lose
money
yeah
how do you think about this kind of
stuff
what you're describing is what's
becoming
a pretty normal thing in the nft world
where it's it's called utility nft where
yeah it's not just about the artwork you
know so many people have heard the name
of beeple or any other you know the
bigger x copy the bigger nft artist and
like that's pretty straightforward it's
jpeg it looks great you collect it you
hang it on your wall done deal you're
never getting anything else but it is a
piece of art right yeah so the utility
nft world is one where when you do buy
the nft it comes with additional unlocks
and those can be both online offline
they could be things like with the board
apes when they had their
token that they launched you so you got
some ape token that came along with it
that had some liquidity to it it could
be all slew of different things
so
it is a slippery slope and it is
something i would certainly
buyer beware for sure unless they are
taking it serious enough to build a real
team around it and considering it a
business like what we do at proof with
the proof collective
membership is it's very much a business
for us like it's a corporation we have
employees we have payroll we have all of
that and it is a new type of media
company that we're building from the
ground up so i don't see it as something
i can imagine one is put on the
shoulders of an individual like if it
was just you doing it at a tim nft where
you have to manage your discord and do
meetups and all that like yeah that
sounds horrible right yeah yeah but but
it's and the other thing too is you do
have to think about end of life for
these particular
utility entities so i think the ones
that
you're right in that you can imagine a
world where
if you have a utility nft and it ends at
three years you know what happens to the
price at two years and six months like
what do people start bailing on and
who's the buyer if there's any buyers at
all right like it just plummets in value
and people lose all this money so
our solution and what i came up with
with the proof collective and
again
this is like with tim's nft i'm not
telling you to go buy this first of all
they're outrageous right now so thousand
memberships
it's um the current price is three
hundred thousand dollars for membership
and it's amazing but we set a three-year
limit on this actual on the benefits
right so you get that we're four months
into a three-year membership so what
happens at year two like what it what to
this insanely like you know crazy asset
so
we figured out that there's two things
that happen and for us one we're working
with well we will be working with a very
well-known nft artist to convert and
swap out the artwork from a membership
card
into a real piece of art
so
at a thousand you can do that you can
make them scarce and rare and you can
make them actually individually
collectible and we're going to have to
pay this artist because the one that i'm
thinking at that we're talking to
it's going to be a very expensive like
million dollar plus kind of check to to
write to go and have this artist do
something really unique but then when it
expires and that swap happens at the
last day you're like okay i have value
here because this is a real real art nft
right and then of course at the very end
you do things like
there's a season two maybe they get a
half discount off into the next season
or whatever it may be so there's there's
ways to mitigate some of that
there's no perfect solution but i think
that is the best that i've come up with
to date is is really making it something
that can stand on its own even when
membership goes away or the benefits go
away i think super smart when you
described that to me it was the first
time i had
heard of that type of
kind of time-bound
conversion
event
super clever right it's it's it's very
clever and i think it highlights also
how as you said
if you're going to participate in
anything
that has a value predicated on future
deliverables and roadmaps like make sure
that you do the diligence to evaluate
the team behind it yeah i mean
like really make sure you do that
because
holy speculation batman like there's a
lot of action in the space and you need
to
yeah if you don't have a good way to
assess teams or if you don't have an
approach to that then don't do it a lot
of people talk about something called
fudd and they don't like it it says fear
uncertainty and doubt yeah and in the
nft world they'll be like don't spread
fud don't spread fud but i'm actually of
the opposite
in the spectrum and that i believe flood
is actually a good thing like we need to
have fear uncertainty and doubt in each
of these projects and properly evaluate
them like yeah there's there's there's
multiple fears when it comes to nfts
raising money if there's a fear around
the use of proceeds what are they going
to do are they going to disappear after
they receive the money there's fears
around execution risk are they going to
actually deliver on their promises
there's market fears like
crypto is very lumpy does this drop in
value by half like you need to really
evaluate these things and make sure
there's a credible team behind them
before you go into them yeah and also
like pointing out risks is not
fud
no
so so fudd just to just do
just to use this in a in a context where
i have exposure to it
so fear uncertainty and doubt
usually when i've run into it in tech
right so my first job out of college was
selling storage area networks fiber
channel
in competition against network appliance
and emc and so on
and the bigger companies would use fear
uncertainty and doubt but it wasn't
always based on fact right they would
just if some if we were close to winning
an account
they would to say well hey they're a
startup yes they have funding but how
long do you think they're going to be
around you just don't know right like
they might be around in five years but
they might be out of business what
happens to your service contract who
manages the upkeep if you have issues
with firmware what's going to happen
when you need to swap it out if they run
out of funding right so that type of
kind of
intimidation through uncertainty
is is kind of one
type of flood but
if
if we are
off a certain
coastline in south africa and there are
seals in the water and it's full of
great white sharks and i'm like maybe
you don't want to go in there because
there are a lot of great white sharks if
your response is stop selling me fud man
everything's gonna be okay
then you might just have your arms
bitten off
right like there's actually like a
factual yeah and you're gonna bleed out
at that point yeah oh yeah you're gonna
bleed out it's it's not it's not a good
situation very hard to swim with no arms
so
so i will say that
not to not to get all i'm surprised i'm
so amped up i haven't had that much
caffeine today i'm feeling feeling
pretty good
you have to be very cautious to quote
warren buffett because you can't really
lose quoting warren buffett so why not
don't ask a barber if you need a haircut
right so like if someone has a vested
interest in something
right and they're telling you
everything's gonna be all right because
their wallet is gonna take a hit if it
doesn't
go up and to the right
they are not an unbiased source of
information right and and you know a lot
of what's happening in nft world just to
just to mention it real briefly like
there's a story i heard long time ago
it was actually an anecdote that this
guy told
this pretty shady cat this guy who was
involved in infomercials and i happen to
be like sitting around a table and he
was telling the story to someone else
this was way back in like early 2000s
and he was telling it like this this
grand
lesson that he was like bestowing upon
his
children and i was like oh wow this
guy's really unethical and he told this
long story about
this guy who
who caught this amazing tuna fish and he
canned it and he sold it and then it
sold for ten dollars and then it sold
for a hundred dollars and then like it
sold for a thousand and then ten
thousand and then like a hundred
thousand and then one day somebody who
owns this like hundred thousand dollar
can of tuna fish opened it and it was
totally rotten and so he reached out to
the person who sold it to him and was
like hey you sold me this tuna fish it's
totally rotten and the guy said that
tuna fish isn't for eating that tuna
fish is for selling and yeah like
but i think there's a lot of that
going on right absolutely like the
greater full theory of investing it's
like all right well as long as i can
find someone who does even less
diligence than i did
it'll all work out yep and yeah you got
to be careful
well especially the the other thing too
and it's something i'm trying to figure
out because i am building in the space
is there are a lot of projects that are
coming out and they're
serving very large audiences like the
reason why the the proof collective
stuff we only did a thousand is because
i don't think i could handle more than a
thousand people with this type of stuff
that we want to do on that side and you
know the other projects not to interrupt
but i will again because apparently
that's my thing today and you have
a company building
experience right but managing
expectations and inbound and requests
and complaints from 10 000 people
that is a lot to actually handle well
yeah right and so that's kind of like we
have another project that's coming up
that is 10 000 people big but the the
way that we're we're doing it is is
completely different than what's been
done today because what basically what
happens is when you promise 10 000
people the world
and you have a budget of x
and you divide up that budget and you
send them
you make do on your you're good on your
promise and you send them something in
the mail they get like an engraved pin
in like a hat right like there's not a
whole lot of budget to go around to all
these people
so the way that we we treat things as we
actually in this next project
we kind of do it almost like the airline
miles way that you get different status
based on
your engagement with the community how
long you hold the nft for so that we can
put out different tiers based on how you
actually have committed to the community
we call it it's it's a long story but
it's the project's called moon birds and
it's called nesting but you actually
lock up your asset and then and and you
unlock additional benefits as time goes
on so it's it's a way to divide and
conquer versus trying to promise these
massive benefits to the entire world if
that makes sense so do the people who
hold moon birds
commit to i don't want to say i mean
it's not a vesting schedule like nesting
period in advance is that something they
commit to or is it just however long
they hold it and each day they can
decide if they want to buy or sell or i
guess sell in this case yeah when they
lock it up at the contract level it
prevents it from being sold i see okay
so they do decide up front yeah but they
can they can back out in two seconds at
any time they want it just stops their
continuous streak and and their their
status level basically okay got it
that's interesting yeah but then it
allows me to carve it out because like
if you think about like let's just say
you did a
nft to ten thousand of your fans like
you could say okay well the people that
have actually been with me for let's
just say you did this years ago you can
see the people that were with me for the
last three years and have stuck with me
and been members for that long i will do
that private dinner with you because
it's gonna be 25 or something you know
what i mean it's like it allows you to
like to segment things
i have this private facebook group
for people who supported my
subscription
podcast kind of alternative business
model years ago right and that's still
around and it's amazing it's a much
smaller group
of people right so i could see
possibly doing something along those
lines i don't want to mention the name
but i think you will agree
that the the potential name that i've
been
coming up with ideas for for like last
two years
for this nft project is pretty
phenomenal i think you'll you'll agree
you have a top five pfp name in your in
your repertoire there like
tim has this idea for a big nft drop
that is
is powerful
it would be very hard for people not to
write about it and i expect at least 70
percent of the internet would go oh my
oh my oh yeah how could he how could he
i'd give you a 10 chance of being
canceled with that one going out
it it's it's it's a tim after two
glasses of wine nft project it's
probably like four or five glasses of
wine after four or five glasses of wine
and there is part of me that is like do
i want this to be the most dominant
feature of my wikipedia page uh maybe
not maybe not
right if that's my current activities i
don't know i don't know i do think it
would be
uh ultimately
hilarious it would be
largely
absurdity focused so we'll we'll see if
that ever happens i don't know if it'll
ever happen i want to see i'm actually
super why not though man it's like you
know why not you have nothing to why you
do have a lot to lose
well i mean the you know the nice part
is
i mean what would what would canceling
look like for an nft project that upsets
some people like what is that what does
that really look like right i guess you
have like for you it's like lots of
noises people stop listening to your
podcast or something yeah like i mean
really like if if you've been listening
to the podcast long enough or or
listening to these random shows long
enough right if if you're still
listening like we've had ample
opportunity to
talk about any number of things that
might get to you know cause somebody to
get their knickers knickers in a twist
yeah i mean you literally talked about
anal tobacco yeah we already talked
about anal administration of tobacco
we've talked about
you know i took that like 30-day uh no
what was it it was like no booze no
masturbating experiment without that
audience
and talked about like my you know hey
before you before you go on this porn
fast here are some recommendations like
like this isn't exactly family
programming so right i feel well it
depends on your family i guess
but
oh my god i'm definitely putting tuna
helper in the name of this episode
now i know you i mean you're you've you
have some pretty cool
stuff coming up and very cool stuff
coming up and you've been working so
hard i mean i think it's just hilarious
that like the less
you need to work the
harder you seem to work have you
observed this
i mean
honestly it's funny have you ever met
bill harlan or no
uh do you do you know him at harlan
estate the wines are we talking about
will i know will yeah that's why i was
getting confused yeah he's never met his
dad bill yeah i may have met bill at
i can never pronounce this word it's too
fancy for me coming from long island is
it promontory
promontory yeah promontory jesus i can
never say that word yeah the winery yeah
i may have met bill
when we did a site visit ages ago
i may have but let's just assume not for
the purposes of this conversation so for
people that don't know heartland estate
is
one of the most premier culti wines in
napa valley it's insanely sought after
multi-year wait list just to get access
to an allocation it's like the moon
birds of wine basically right the moon
birds like the nfc you have a high-end
one exactly very very hard to get
so
i've been very lucky to be on that board
and it's given me exposure to just a
world that i would normally never have
any insight into
and they have properties too as well
like meadowwood and the restaurant at
meadow wood which is the three michelin
star restaurant so they have a bunch of
different things that i always learn
about at these board meetings learn from
and hopefully help on the tech side a
little bit in helping them form their
thinking around
new ways to
to embrace current tech so
one of the things that he said to me at
a dinner just like a week ago
we were at this dinner and and bill's in
his 80s now
and we're talking about nfts and how
they're applicable to um potentially to
the wine world in some really
interesting ways there
which i believe will absolutely happen
and he goes he goes he's and i'm
paraphrasing but he's like he's like
kevin i get it he goes when you see
these markets
and and you see it before anyone else
he goes you push in really hard and and
you get the outsized rewards and for him
that was real estate in napa valley you
know 30 years ago that was
and he goes then
you sit around and you wait until you
see the next one and it might be a
decade or longer until you see this next
big moment when it's time to push your
chips in again
and for me
i have been sitting around waiting since
web 2 2004
and granted i was really active in web 2
and there was mobile and there was a few
other amazing things that happened vr
was stupid but then um
you are really doubling down on the vr
stupid thing huh
it'll eventually get to the right size
and price that people will like it but
but i think i think that i had a big
fight with one of your other guests adam
gazzali he told me that vr was going to
take off like five years ago and we bet
a bottle of hibiki 30 when it was a lot
less expensive and he still hasn't sent
me the bottle hit bk30 so oh it's just
going to keep getting more expensive
anyway oh yeah it's getting more
expensive it's like 5x to price instead
so adam cough it up man
so
the long story short is is
i i'll give you a great example i was
working on on the moon birds project
till midnight last night and i woke up
naturally and this is weird for me at 6
00 am got out of bed and started working
again
because there is this excitement there's
this blue ocean there is so much that
can be done in this space
that it's like tim it's like when you
came to the nft conference with me and
we were sharing a a room and you were
sleeping on the couch which was awesome
hilarious you wanted to bed i would not
let you in the bed because the truth is
[ __ ] freezing it got just just a side
note so it was so [ __ ] cold this is
in martha texas got down to like 40
degrees at night and i'm sleeping on the
couch with a towel on top of me it
doesn't even cover like the lower half
of my legs
shivering
dying and i'm like kevin are you sure
there are any blankets he's like no man
no extra blankets and then the last day
i'm like what's that huge drawer on the
other side of the bed pull it out
comforters galore everywhere yeah
exactly
so sorry about that but um
so anyway when we were there you and i
were both feeling that we're getting up
early and talking about interviews like
and it's not just about
the hype cycle it's about this there's a
new technology that is just taking shape
and yes it'll be many years before it's
fully realized but this is when you want
to to start paying attention it's when
there's the most risk of course but
that's that's that early investors you
embrace risk because that's where the
most upside is right so that's what's
exciting about it yeah i would also say
you know just reinforce that i mean it
you know martha definitely had the
feeling like okay we're on the beach in
northern california and this is kind of
the first burning man i get they had
that right or south by southwest like
2007
where interactive was just like the
red-headed step child
sorry trigger warning for redheaded
stepchildren so it's red
stepchild of cancelled south by nobody
cared you know i it's like nobody cared
about interactive and now it is just
as uh not to make this like the and
recent themed show like software eating
the world right now now interactive is
like the glue that holds everything
together
and
i'm not saying that's going to be the
case with nfts necessarily but you
definitely had that and it's more for me
of like a physiological feeling you're
like okay
we're in a really small group
these p there are a lot of very smart
people here who have decided this is
what they want to dedicate all their
time to
right so if you agree with some
investors who take the position that
like what the nerds do on the weekends
now is what everybody will be doing in
like five years or ten years i think
dixon said that right dixon maybe yeah
and it's like okay i do think there's
something to that right and
there's just this fee this like electric
feeling which is is hard to put words to
but it is
it's it's kind of
a physiological response from me and i
talked about this a little bit in the
podcast with with dixon and naval but
that's definitely true for this and i
would also say
like
it is
risky to
what's the right what are the kids the
cool kids saying ape into whale into a
position ape into yeah yeah if you
just take like half your net worth
and
you're not sure how you're gonna
make your mortgage payment and you
push all those chips into something
that's hugely speculative
that's risky but i don't view that as
intelligent risk taking right that is
that's just foolish
and has tremendous downside potential
but if
i do think you can begin to
like place little bets and think about
mitigating downside right absolutely
because if right now we're in a phase
where there are opportunities
for like 5x 10x 100x investments i know
a lot of people have become spoiled over
kovad where they're like
started trading on like robin hood and
this then the other thing and they're
like oh if it's less than a thousand
percent a year like i'm not interested
i'm gonna look for the next best thing
and it's i think that's going to burn a
lot of people but
you can then start to think about like
actually studying some of these older
investors and and learning about
portfolio construction right and
really taking
a like
risk intelligent approach to playing
only with chips you can afford to lose
and i think you get smarter that way oh
absolutely because if you go into it and
you're like
high risk high reward baby and you use
that as a
smoke screen to cover up your complete
lack of due diligence to cover up the
fact that you have no understanding of
the technology to cover up the fact that
you didn't do any homework
on the team behind x y and z that you
saw trending on twitter because you
think that you're gonna make a fast buck
you're just gonna lose your money sooner
or later you will lose your money
but
i'm also seeing people who
are really taking this as an opportunity
to basically like go to grad school
right and they're like okay i'm going to
play with just enough and to everybody i
mean i don't know if you agree with this
or not but from my perspective you know
like i waited
whatever was a year and a half after
we started talking about nfts to launch
my first nft why because i don't think
you need to rush i do not think you need
to rush like it is so early it is still
so early
if anything it's now is the time to
dabble and just have the foundational
knowledge so that when you're ready to
have an informed decision and push in
and do something you aren't starting
from from zero right so you know i
oftentimes tell people they're like how
do i get started mts and i'm like okay
it's easy you you have to learn how to
use metamask and you have to learn how
to send and one eth to that wallet or
two hundred dollars with the e to that
wallet like you know you have to learn
how to safeguard your secret phrase like
there's some foundational knowledge
that's going to be essential for this
world and and now's the time to start
even if you don't want to spend anything
on nfts now is the time to get that base
knowledge down
so when you're ready you can you can
pull the trigger
uh i was just laughing because i went to
this conference recently you know i'm
thinking about you and just cutting as
you are with all these things and so
neck deep and everything and
you know able to look around corners and
i was at this conference because you
know i haven't been to conferences in
forever
uh with the exception of the marfa thing
but that wasn't really a conference
right that was just like that was tiny
little thing yeah hanging out and having
barbecue and just bullshitting and
talking about the the potential amazing
future that we have ahead of us with
respect to these technologies but i went
to like a conference conference
and uh i was
kind of going to these sessions and
going to these dinners and everybody was
asking me
you'll appreciate this this is going to
sound weird to a lot of people listening
but
the everyone had like their new big
project like yeah my new big project and
so they'd be like so they like look at
my name badge and they'd be like oh tim
flores podcast okay you have podcasts
your podcast about and i'd be like ah
it's an interview podcast and they'd be
like looking over my shoulder for like
another finance person to talk to they'd
be like all right this guy this guy's
boring and then they'd be like and
they'd be like so what's what's your
what's your what's your new big project
what's your gigantic new project you're
focused on and the best thing i could
come up with in part because i didn't
really want to talk to these people but
it's kind of true i was like i'm mostly
trying to figure out how to talk to
animals right now
what
what and then
and then they like they'd be like oh
that's uh that's that's fascinating and
then they'd like walk off with their
little hors d'oeuvres like a glass of
champers to find somebody else to like
give a ted talk to but
yeah i feel like i'm kind of going the
opposite direction like i've become
super fascinated and i have been
fascinated by like animal tracking
specifically
so leave putting aside like the animal
communication piece that's a whole
separate
can of worms but
like tracking
one of the oldest human skills
imaginable it's also an animal skill of
course but it's like okay who are the
best trackers in the world like if you
need to track a given ad oh that's so
much fun what a fun hobby yeah so i've
become i've been reading book after book
after book and
you
as one would expect there's a lot of
horseshit and
[Music]
a boatload of charlatans who claim to be
like oh i was trained by
whatever a such-and-such scout from
such-and-such tribe and you're like okay
there's no way for me to possibly verify
that you know what i mean yeah so i have
you know it could just be ghost stories
this person is telling me uh but there
are still
folks who are exceptionally good so
that's that's something i'm leaning into
so if anybody has any thoughts on that
where you can actually verify these
people know what they do hit me up on
twitter at t ferris t f e r r i says
anything else you'd like to mention
kevin before we
cut out because i know we're coming up
on time
yeah i mean i guess the only thing is
i'm at kevin rose if you want to follow
my adventures on twitter mostly around
all things crypto and nfts moon birds is
our new launch that's coming out it's
you most likely are just gonna have to
find in the secondary market because
it's been insanely oversubscribed
but it should be a really fun utility
nft
that you should check out
yeah and uh
always good to see you brother yeah i'll
be along for the moon bird ride so uh
i'm excited about that i really
appreciate that you're always willing to
be like the first monkey shot into space
at least between the two of us with
stuff like this then i get to
i get to have front row seats to all the
lessons you have to watch as my capsule
comes back down and and what's going to
happen to the shoots deployed
yeah yeah it's awesome so that so thank
you for that cool you made the space
okay let's see what that capsule does
let's see how the return goes yeah
goes exactly i'm so excited for you man
i'll just say real quickly in passing
and i've said this to you before but
it's so fun
for me
to see
like a playing field and a sport and a
set of technologies that is so perfectly
suited to like all of the circles
that overlapped to form the venn diagram
that is kevin rose like like you said
thank you it's been a long time since
i've seen you this excited about
something where this is
all you're doing i mean i mean of course
you have family and you're a good dad
you good good husband you're doing all
of that you're not neglecting everything
else but
like you are on fire right now and it's
so fun to watch it just makes me it
makes me happy to see you so excited
about something
thank you i appreciate that i'm it it
feels so i'm telling you this is the way
it's always been for me and i'm sure you
can relate is when you find something
that you like really personally love
like you really getting up at six
doesn't matter because it doesn't feel
like you're working at all you know yeah
yeah you have bigger batteries it lasts
longer exactly good for you man well
it's good to see you brother and thanks
for taking the time to jam yeah let's
hang in person soon let's do it and uh
folks we'll have links to various
resources and so on in the show notes as
usual 10. blog
podcast and until next time
thank you for tuning in
okay bye
take care
you